[Music]
[Applause]
he's the quarterback of my vikings
and i had fritzi call up the vikings on
friday and say after the vikings beat
the packers see if kirk cousins would
like to join us on the program
and i don't know if that was motivation
for you kirk but uh congratulations on
the win
thank you so much
sounds like we got you the win too so
that's good but uh happy to be on always
good to see your face it was over a
decade ago i first came on the show as a
as a college athlete and and sang and
everything and so uh it's good as all
these years have gone by where i'm still
talking to you well you know i go back
to that
do you think friday
like wasn't that big ten title weekend
versus russell yes it was it was after
either the hail mary game we played
wisconsin russell wilson or one of those
one of those close games but um
wow yeah and i my singing days are over
i'm retired now but you look back on
that and russ didn't wasn't a
first-round draft pick you certainly
weren't but here you are
you know surviving i guess um but i
maybe you don't view it as surviving but
it just seems like
the critics are never going to be happy
enough with what you do
right do you get that yeah i think
i think being a first round pick really
does help when it comes to
you know people kind of being in your
corner for most of your career you're
supposed to have success it just kind of
comes with the draft i think the draft
does follow you a little bit for your
career and that's okay but um no in that
draft you know nick foles the super bowl
mvp was a third round pick as well so
there were a few guys there that
you know that have carved out long
careers in that draft class i'm proud to
be a part of those those quarterbacks
take me into the huddle
when justin jefferson seemed to be
single covered the entire afternoon
i what are you thinking as the game goes
on and what kind of conversations did
you have with justin
yeah every week we kind of have this
dialogue with the coaches and with
justin of we need to see early in the
game how they're defending you
everybody's going to have a plan and
then we have to have a plan to counter
it and i do think green bay had a plan
they had a good plan they were aware of
where he was they were going to help
have a safety help over top of him
but we were just still trying to find
creative ways when i say we mostly the
coaches just finding creative ways to
still get him involved and getting the
ball and if we did get single higher we
did get that one-on-one that we don't
miss those opportunities and then to
justin's credit um you know just making
great plays and having a big catch
radius and even when there's somewhat
tight coverage being able to still make
the play
well that's a luxury though as a
quarterback when if that's your bailout
like you just kind of put it in the area
and it feels like he's going to go get
it
yeah well said when the when um when the
ball goes up you expect him to go get it
and um
i i pride myself on being an accurate
quarterback i think that's one of the
reasons i'm still playing football but
um i don't have to be quite as accurate
with him if i miss by a foot here or
there he tends to make up the difference
which i appreciate how was it having a
brand new head coach a rookie head coach
and kevin you know going out how nervous
was he was he more nervous than you
he projected pretty calm demeanor um you
know going into the game and saturday
night as he talked to the team
he was his usual self i think that for
me i was a little bit
whatever you want to call it nerves i
mean the combination of week one brings
nerves and then the fact that we didn't
play in the preseason
most of our starters didn't really get
to go so
with a new coach and not having done the
dress rehearsal quite the same way as we
have in the past
i was a little bit more uneasy than as
if we had had a bunch of pre-season work
together but i was it was great to go
out there on the very first drive and
score a touchdown and feel like okay i
guess i guess the cobwebs weren't there
too badly and we're ready to go
you want more preseason action or less
as a starter
i i think it's this risk reward thing i
mean there was a reason we didn't play i
just think it was hey we want everybody
healthy week one last year we we played
uh at kansas city in preseason game
three and we lost our tight ender smith
for the entire season with a knee injury
so there's a realization that uh when
you play in the preseason there's a
chance something can go wrong there's
also benefit to getting out there
playing with live bullets you know
wearing a red jersey in practice really
doesn't simulate the real thing but
these joint practices where we practice
against san francisco leading into our
preseason game against them have in some
ways started to replace preseason games
and coaches are trying to use those
practice days as high intensity days
that can simulate the real thing
aaron rodgers had thrown 38 touchdowns
without an interception against the nfc
north before being picked off by
harrison smith in week one
what do you see when you watch aaron
rodgers play
ah just tremendous respect for his game
do you watch on the sidelines
well i
i i watched less yesterday than i
probably normally would or normally do
for whatever reason um
but um
you know he he's he's tremendous and and
the game's never over with him you know
we were up by
16 and with one minute left you know we
wanted to stay in bounds to keep the
clock running and we ended up running
out of bounds and stopped the clock with
about a minute seven left and i said
i believe that number 12
could go down get a two get a touchdown
two-point conversion onside kick
touchdown two-point conversion and we're
going to overtime with only a minute
seven left i i believe that can happen
and so
um i really wasn't sitting easy until
the clock hit zero yeah but i think you
have to have that mentality because you
like you just don't go yeah they can't
do that and and it's aaron rodgers i
mean there are a couple of quarterbacks
where you just can't go yeah that's not
possible and and i think that's a good
mindset we're talking to kirk cousins
vikings quarterback uh two touchdowns in
week one no turnovers
by the way more importantly
uh the vikings go to philadelphia next
week that'll be spicy all right we uh
we're we're trying to come up with a bet
on the yellow plaid shirt you had on
yesterday after the game all right
so we want to guess the brand
of the yellow plaid shirt
that kirk cousins had on yes pauline i
know kirk's wardrobe in style pretty
well
i've been tracking it for years okay you
know he's a sensible shopper yeah he you
know got the big contract i'm gonna go
patagonia lovely
okay uh fritzy i'm gonna go hollister
hollister
seton
i'm gonna go ll bean all right marv
i'm gonna go eddie bauer oh that's a
good guess i'm gonna go rei
all right and i wish i wish it was l.l
bean or eddie bauer maybe that fits my
brand a little more but my wife dresses
me by the way
it happened to be patagonia and uh
sitting around the house yesterday about
11 30 before heading to the stadium
and i said uh because i do nothing in
fashion i make no decision so i looked
at my wife and i said have you laid my
outfit out on the bed of the game
and she said no i got to go do that so i
i finished my lunch and then went up
there and sure enough that shirt and a
pair of pants and a pair of socks and a
pair of shoes was sitting right there on
the bed next to the bed and i put it on
and got in the car and headed the
stadium so i just do what she tells me
there's been a few moments where i uh i
shake my head i said there's no way i
should wear this no way
and she says wear it and then adam felin
and justin jefferson and kj osborne look
at me and say you look good yesterday
you did a good job so i stopped uh
trying to speak into it a long time ago
i just do what she tells me um
and you know don't mess with the wife
you know when she she plans you know but
i can see it did does she put the pants
on the bed and the shirt on the bed and
then the shoes and the socks right
underneath the the pants
yep and then the belt is also there and
so and believe me i've learned from my
teammates and their fits that one you
know the wrong belt can screw up the
whole thing so everything's got to be
thought through and uh
away games we tend to bring a little bit
more you know suit and tie kind of a
look
but home games a little more dressed
down but
it's fun i don't want to be involved in
making those decisions but it's fun to
have something and i love more
importantly watching what my teammates
wear because you get some crazy outfits
okay who walks in and you go oh my god
so olabisi johnson uh was was you know
last couple years his fits were just
getting more and more out there and then
uh stefan diggs was always really really
interesting really creative with what he
would bring
um you know justin's starting to now
rock uh the chains and he's got the
grills now that you put in so uh
you know it's it's getting out there
it's fun it's entertaining for me
um would you ever do something like that
well i thought about doing the ryan
fitzpatrick when he uh he grabbed the
sean jackson's outfit and went to the
post-game press conference with it on
you know that would that would fit me
but ryan kind of beat me to it so um
uh you know but the fashion thing is is
a lot of fun
well congrats hey as long as you keep
beating the packers you know it doesn't
matter what you wear
no we've had some good battles against
them uh you know
beat them lost to them tied to them it
goes back and forth and uh you know the
key is you know they've won the division
the last few years and that's really
where we want to be is winning the north
and hosting a home playoff game so
that's where we want to be at the end of
this thing what happens at the end of
the game when the quarterbacks get
together like is anything really
meaningful in those conversations
i think it comes down a little bit to
how much you know the other quarterback
you know nick foles and i were college
teammates for a year so if i see him
after a game you know it's going to be a
little different conversation than uh
you know a guy who's 10 years older than
me and so and with aaron you know it's
usually to shake his hand uh you know he
he says you know have a good season stay
healthy and i i usually remind him he's
probably the best in the world and uh
and then i go my separate way but uh is
he the best quarterback
uh
i mean
it's kind of that conversation of like
you know they're all they're all great
at the top but um
i think the bodywork and the two mvps
last year and until he's proven
otherwise i think um
in in my book you know he's he's doing
it as well as anybody's and and uh the
elite level he plays that week in and
week out protecting the football and all
that
um yeah i think he's he's pretty special
what do you say to brady after a game
uh
well usually you know
the three times i've played him you know
i've been on the losing end so just
shake his hand and head to the locker
room but um
you know one game he i don't know if he
was upset with how he played they won i
don't know if he was like player ever
but he he uh just took off you know took
off to the locker room i think he was uh
he's just so competitive sometimes he
doesn't feel like saying hello to too
many people but um
uh
you know another guy who
when he was winning his first super bowl
i was in middle school
now i'm in my 11th year in the league
i'm one of the oldest guys in our locker
room and he's still playing so it just
goes to show the longevity of some of
these quarterbacks
uh tell your wife good game you know
because
i mean it's a team effort here
tonight yes
uh hey great to talk to you again
congrats thank you uh for joining us
absolutely thanks guys good seeing you
that's kirk cousins vikings quarterback
three-time pro bowler and a couple of
touchdown passes almost had another one
with justin jefferson
what a luxury though